bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono a vincere ed
oggi siamo su murdoch bar dei dovrebbe
ragazzi esser vorrei giungendo il di
bocchetti mario contento che il
protagonista protagonista di questo
videogioco e uno dog con le gambe cioè
io non l'ho capito che cazzo di sé
scelto sto gioco perché mi sembra di un
intelligenza fuori dal mondo e non
potevano giocare ragazzi allora
facciamolo skip to tò realta che tanto
siamo dei pro e quindi lo facciamo senza
mai così aiutatevi ragazzi e che oggi
tutorial non li faccio mai nei
videogiochi ogni volta parto senza farli
bellissimo come cazzo si gioca fini
ragazzi il mio obiettivo dovrebbe essere
quello di arrivare a fine di bello come
cat mario insomma soltanto si ok non so
come ho fatto perfetto tanti ragazzi se
non sbaglio si possono tirare ica
infatti possibile cioè cazzo sta facendo
posso tirare dei calci insulti alle cose
cioè non chiedetemi come quindi credo di
poter calciare quel coltello con le
gambe che forse così c'è il tiro della
madonna
ok traversa effetto ragazzi fin qui
tutto facile credo di poter arrivare
anche abbastanza avanti ma [ __ ] me
l'ha messo nel deretano perfetto che
ragazzi devo schivare i coltelli tipo
non devo farmi non devo farlo mettere
nei cup ranzi dei coltelli perfetto via
ok non posso tirarmi uno stato un attimo
da un attimo tuca tuca che cazzo
sto testando madonna santa c'è da
spiegatemi come fanno i coltelli a
sanguigna dove il tasso dove dov'è il
tasto donna era la b la b ma porca vacca
da ragazzi ce la possiamo fare carminati
ma vaffan cuore tuo devo ok ok
ok perfetto perfetto prefetto calmi
adesso devo calciare li prepotenza 12
perfetto ma anche all'altro che li sopra
che il gigantesco tipo la spesa è un
attimo allora facciamo così questo lo
togliamo ma perché sanguinano i coltelli
fatemi capire solca pure tu questa razza
successo dei ragazzi e faccia fate finta
di niente come se non avessi fatto nulla
si può andare lassù
credo di no forse muoio infatti non
sapevo perché ci sono andato solo sapevo
porca [ __ ] attento al divieto lo zio
buca 1 suo cazzo devi solo morire
raga non ho capito dove devo andare
credo di qua sinistra infatti allora poi
salto a perfetto era era più semplice di
quanto pensassimo una forchetta una
forchetta [ __ ] anche a lei è ancora
li chiama contro il muro perfetto senti
1a mi stai simpatica quindi non rompermi
le palle e il montenero però the ok ok
come non detto mori e basta non capito
ancora dove devo arrivare l'obiettivo ho
vinto ho vinto cos'è sta roba
sì ho vinto perfetto o chiara la prima
livello andato penso che adesso sia un
po più difficile tipo che inizieranno a
spuntare anche i piatti forze l'altro
cesta scatola che sto calciando che sta
facendo disastri vai così maledetta
forchetta ma oriente tutti ragazza oggi
in avanti dichiaro guerra le posate
sappiatelo mamma mia mamma mia altro che
ronaldinho questo palleggia meglio no no
ok canicani devo devo tipo lanciarla da
qualche parte no si ok la mamma me la
sto partendo dietro ma mi serve
effettivamente qualcosa perché sto
facendo stragi ancora non ho capito dove
stiamo andando
ok ok ancora i ragazzi non ho capito
dove stiamo andando
[ __ ] sapevo ragazzi ma scherzi devo
rifarmi tutto ma siete pazzi
no ma sono pazzi questi devo rifarmi
veramente tutto ma [ __ ] gorica con
la loro incredibile avanza alla strage
contro la forchetta il calcio ragazzi
sta diventando tragico sto gioco ancora
non ho capito dove devo arrivare ma
comunque avete mai visto in vita vostra
1 doggy con le ali bene da adesso
ragazzi questo ve lo porta a perfetto
vedi che serviva qualcosa lo sapevo ci
avrei scommesso devo saltare tipo lì
sopra vai fuori dalla mano
ok ce l'ho fatta anche senza perfetto
andiamo avanti qui ok sta diventando più
difficile ragazzi ve lo dico perché sto
trovando difficoltà anch'io che culo
assurdo appena avuto incredibile non so
se riuscirò mai a fare una cosa del
genere
l'importante è che ti levi dalle palle
ok cano piano piano a [ __ ] non lo
sapevo raga non ce la farò fottutamente
mai più si tua sorella pure cosa cazzo
perché vi si è chiuso il gioco perché
nei regi lagni si deve chiudere il gioco
tutto quanto senza morire neanche la
volta ci voglio provare non so se ci
riesco ma se ci riesco devono farmi un
monumento 2 ora che prova a fare sto
livello di prima donna santissimo faccio
una sola non si può e mezz'ora che
faccio un [ __ ] che è successo adesso
il cazzo ragazzi ci siete ancora aiuto
allora ragazzi diciamo che abbiamo
qualche problema ok non voglio
sbilanciarmi di più buono o no
ok mi sono sbilanciato un pochettino me
non me ne frega un cazzo ma dobbiamo
andare alla fine disco livello senza che
si spenga il [ __ ] gioco ok non è
difficile non è difficile molon mogol
mugione
impossibile non e io non ci voglio
veramente ci voglio credere
ragazzi io da oggi in avanti dichiara
fottutamente guerra gli eau dopo ok ok
poi ragazzi allora arrivò qui non è
difficile mio dio che cazzo se io
veramente non c'è porca [ __ ] e poi
ragazze inquietante il fatto che cesta
musica di sottofondo che è così da
quando abbiamo iniziato una cosa
inguardabile
anzi inascoltabile ma non importa
andiamo avanti così perché tanto non ce
la farò mai brutta stronza ok ok ok ok
ok [ __ ] ma non è partito questo va
bene ragazzi ci stiamo ha forse forse
perché non ci sbilanciamo troppo
riuscendo sento avverrà qui sento
veramente in dovere di denunciare chi
cazzo in 28 sto gioco perché non si può
fare ok ok
sì sì sì ok sono ok ragazzi ci siamo ci
siamo incredibile devo arrivare alla
fine alla fine del livello senza morire
perché sono l'inizio da capo e non è
fattibile non è fatti ok ok sto
diventando cioccio l'ansia cazzo soul
anzi non ci posso credere non ci posso
credere
devi morire
[Musica]
ok cazzo ce l'ho fatta non statali sopra
la statale no no no no
ok ragazzi ci siamo dopo altre sei ore
di tentativi
io non ci posso adesso ce la devo fare è
lì il punto è fottutamente il punto non
è possibile che non ci sia riuscito fino
adesso adesso sì adesso sì sì è la fine
del livello
alla fine del livello devi morire e devi
morire è morto ok ok
sì sì ce l'abbiamo fatta [ __ ] anni
per finire sta merda
io non penso sia normale che per che
cosa ci sono delle aquile che tentano di
prendere un hot dog cioè non ho capito a
sta cosa
partiamo sempre di qui grazie a dio è la
cosa è